Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to would you rather are you ready to compromise your integrity for a bunch of,
I dunno,
Personal satisfaction, you don't really get anything out of it. You just get a conundrum that makes you going to stay awake at night.
So let's get into it. Would you rather have your elbow joints facing the opposite direction or have your knees facing backwards?
(Thinks just as hard as he did with the banana)
Well, see,
If you had your elbows going the other way, you could always surprise people behind you with a hug. (barely makes it through and starts laughing)
(Giggling now) Like, if someone's following you too close in line and your elbows were going the wrong way, you'd just like,
"Ha! I got you!"
(I think we lost him)
"Is this true love?"
(Yup, he's already gone)
It'd be like turning my feet backwards and...
Oh, man, that's no good. If you had your knees facing backwards, that'd just...it'd just make sitting hard. You'd have to sit--
You'd always have to do that cool lean where you turn a chair around backwards and sit in it
the opposite direction. But instead of your legs being out to the side, they're sitting normally in the chair... which would be weird.
I like the reverse hug option. That's that's what I would go for. That's what I want
I want a whole lot of that in my life.
Would you rather eat a container of butter or drink a bottle of maple syrup?
(Deep inhale)
So, you either get a whole bunch of fat or you get a whole bunch of sugar. Now, given that I just got through Keto,
(giggles in admittance) I actually have eaten the container of butter.
There's video of me online where I bite into a whole stick of butter. If you don't know Keto is, it's that diet
where you eat a lot of fat. It works, it sucks, but hey, I did it. I'll take the butter.
I'll choose the road I've traveled versus the road that'll probably kill me.
I'll choose the road that I know will kill me versus the road that will probably kill me. I'll take the butter.
Oh, you big babies. Butter's delicious. (Somehow I doubt that)
I mean, obviously so is maple syrup, but, hey, I'll take the butter.
If you were convicted of a crime, would you rather... (Eyes widen at the conundrum) Ooh, this is a conundrum.
Go to jail for life or have the death penalty...
(That is a good conundrum face)
I mean, it says convicted of a crime. It doesn't mean that I actually did it. But,
man, It's like what would be the point in me dying?
You know what I mean? Like, would there be a point in me dying
for that crime? Would I rather have the death penalty or go to jail?
I'm pretty sure I would still rather have the opportunity to go to jail, because it doesn't say there's no room for parole.
Because that c-- That is an option. I could have parole and be under house arrest,
Or...you know... you know I could still spend my life in jail trying to do something, like,
worthwhile (I just realized he likes to say like a lot). Like, I don't have to march down death row and go right into that, so I'll go to jail. Thank you.
Whoa!
That's actually surprising!
That's actually surprising.
People would rather... More people would rather have the death penalty than go to jail.
What do you guys think about this? Like, I would love to know the reasoning behind that because, obviously,
being in jail for life is a miserable existence. It's almost like, like... (Don't hurt yourself, Mark)
Especially here in America, It's like... what? Like, is it even worth it, but just to like embrace death like that?
And I mean it's like not like I'm afraid of dying, but there's still more that I could do
if I was in jail for life. But, even if it affected a very limited number of people,
It's not like I could do my let's plays from jail, but you know.
I dunno. I dunno.
Would you rather be Aquaman or be The Human Torch? So, it'd be always wet or
always on fire. Is that what you're asking me? Would I rather always be slightly Damp or
always just be a little too tutzy in my putzy? I don't know what a putzy is. I dunno. Let's ignore that one.
The Human Torch can fly, so let's not forget about that fact. Aquaman although, in the new
version of it with that one guy who was Carl...
Cal Drogo. A big old man with big old beard and big Ol muscles and big trident.
I mean, I always thought that Aquaman was cooler than everybody let on. Like,  "Eugh, he talks with fish."
Also he's king of the sea, so how about that? I'm not king of the land up here, but he can...
The Human Torch can fly...
I'll be Aquaman. I'll be Aquaman. That seems pretty badass, get to bang the mermaids all day. That sounds pretty good.
I knew I'd be in the minority on that one,
But I think I'll take that one. Would you rather never listen to music again or never play video games again now?
I may have come across this before, but my life has changed a little bit.
I've actually been finding myself listening to music more and more. I've been listening to Ed Sheeran non-stop,
But also I've been going into, like, I've been listening to The Sign of the Times by Harry Styles,
and I've also been listening to, uh,
Alesha Cara and and a little bit of James Arthur here and there, and I've been slowly meandering my way through new Musicians
So I'm kind of getting into it. Oh! Also, James Reznov McGee just pointed out some video games contain music.
Oh yes. If I had to play video games without music, like...
(More Contemplating. Where's the Banana when you need it?)
Huh, I guess I could play board games. That'd be pretty cool. I wouldn't be able to do Let's Plays again,
That's for sure, but hey, I I needed to remove the copyrighted music anyway. AH! IT'S A DILEMMA!
If I picked one, I wouldn't be able to do Let's Plays. If I picked the other, I wouldn't be able to do music.
I'm gonna pick Listening to Music.
Oh, would I rather never play video games again. That's a little backwards. Okay, would you rather never play video games again?
I'll pick that one.
Okay, all right. I'm just gonna go throw that out there because I think I picked backwards
But I also may have picked the way
I just picked because I may have read the question wrong and I have no idea.
Would you rather be locked in a New York City studio apartment with 400 pugs for a year...You mean Heaven!
Or be forced to round up all the plugs in the US and put them on a boat bound for North Korea?
I think I'll take the studio apartment because number one, that sounds great because my bed would be pugs.
(Starts laughing at the adorability) My Toilet, it would be pugs. My kitchen would be pugs. I wouldn't be able to touch the floor.
I'd have to....
I'd have to get a bunch of monkey bars up in the top of the ceiling and like clamber over and have like a strong Hammock.
But also, I have... (Instant Realization) Oh, God, The Poop.
Oh, God, the poop. Oh, try to walk 400 pugs.
Oh, I wouldn't be...I'm lock... I'd be locked in there. Oh man. How are they gonna eat? I know what I'm gonna eat!
No!
(Don't cry, Mark. :'( )
Oh,
God!
Cuz you're locked in there, right?
(Holds his head in terror) Eventually you'd have to watch them all tear each other apart! Oh, God!
This heaven is unraveling around me!
Oh my God, that actually... If you think about that, that's actually horrible.
I mean, if you just round them up and send them off to North Korea,
Hey,
Maybe that's gonna change their life and, hey, you may not even be get through rounding them all up before you die, so that could
take forever. You'd have to round up them all? That means you have to convince people to give up their pugs
And that ain't gonna happen, so you'd be conversing with them,
you'd being stuck in legal paperwork for years. That's better than drowning in pug vomit and poop and pee and
corpses of pugs, I'll take that one now that I think about it. I'll take that one. Oh.
Okay, would you rather attempt to survive a computer uprising as in terminator or attempt to survive an zombie Outbreak (Dawn of The Dead)? Okay,
So there's a certainty of death in both of these and the computer uprising in terminator,
They nuked about 90% of the population. A lot of people died right away,
But in a zombie apocalypse, a lot of people die right away
And I'd probably be one of them either way here.
It only says attempt to survive because I'm pretty sure that I would not do very well. And with the computer
Uprising, hey, at least the Earth in good hands with computers after we're all gone. If a zombie outbreak happens,
Hey, nothing gets done,
So I'll take dying in the computer uprising versus dying in the zombie outbreak
Because that seems horrible.
I mean, this is horrible
But at least you're going to die quick with a laser to the face or a nuke to the ass.
I'll take that one. I'll take that one. Everyone's like "Oh, Walking Dead."
Nah, you'd be fodder too. maybe like five percent of you, you'd be survivors, or whatnot. Maybe you're immune
I don't know but majority of you, me included, we're going to be zombie food.
Would you rather discover the Loch Ness Monster or  discover Sasquatch? okay. Here's where I have a problem with this:
The Loch Ness Monster. if you're stuck discovering the Loch Ness Monster,
That means you're in the middle of that lake when you discover it because I have a funky feeling that you're not going to be, oh,
fishing on the shore and all Sudden,
Old Nessie pops his head out of the ocean be like or the sea or the lake or the loch and be all like...
"Hey, whatcha doing? 3.50 joke. Deduhdebuduh." I think the only way you're gonna discover
loch ness is when you're in a little dinky rowboat out in the middle of the sea loch and
And you like top-down view you just see huge jaws just coming up under your boat from underwater. (Thats a frightening image) But you don't notice it.
Oh, you're like, "Oh, so serene now that there's no Loch Ness" and then as it's Jaws start to close on your boat,
you're like,
"I Discovered you!" Dead, and you're gone. That's how that works. you discover the sasquatch
Hey, maybe you can do buddies. I've seen the commercials. Pick the Sasquatch.Yeah. Oh, fine, whatever.
Well if you could choose an age to stay forever would you rather be 21 or be 10? Why would you choose to be 10?
Let me think of a reason why you choose to be done, okay?
What do you have at 10 you're not a teenager yet?
You haven't gone through Puberty you got your childlike innocence people tend to like I
Don't know no one likes you actually you're just annoying a 10 you're kind of annoying you gotten out of the cute kid phase
But you're not quite in the teen phase you're just a little kind of ratty brat
so if you're 21
That seems like great
Who wouldn't I can't pick up with do you guys have a single reason why you would want to be ten forever I?
Would I would want to be this seems obvious
Why am I thinking so hard about this the 21 is obvious you're almost at your peak you're almost fully grown
Like you're in the peak of your youth you're you're you're officially an adult you get to do
Anything you want if you're ten you're just a kid not like your brain hasn't developed fully yet
So you got that childlike innocence that stupid bullshit childlike innocence?
21:8 work, whatever you want to do ass 21 good
would you rather be hunted by people or hunt people so this is like the the the the per
Being hunted by people you may have the Moral high ground
But you also probably got a bullet to the heart if you hunt people you got the moral low ground
But also probably you're going to get a bullet to the heart I don't like either of these I
did it
Today, they take whatever world were in when this has to happen
It's quite a conundrum here, so I'm just gonna go out hunt me just hunt me just haunt me. I'll be fair game
I'll make it interesting for you. I'll do a dance before you shoot. That's what I'll do
I'll make I'll make it good for you. Oh
Would you rather have a flying car?
Or have a one terabyte per second internet connection
I've recently just got gigabit internet
And it's amazing I cannot imagine what Terabyte internet would unlock first
But a flying car, I'm assuming you're the only one that has it because that doesn't exist in the world here
So then you could use that to patent it you could reverse engineer and like secure a future for yourself and then buy a one
Terabyte internet connection, but also with a one terabyte entered per second internet connection you could start your own hosting company
You could do unlimited number of things with I'm assuming. You don't have to pay for this thing. Maybe you do
I don't know. I'm assuming it comes for free like he just happened stamped upon it all right
I'm gonna leave this one to you. I'm gonna leave this one to you
There's pluses and minuses here because is the benefit of one Terabyte internet Connection is
unreal
because it's
Carabid sorry it's one terabit per second which is still an ungodly amount. That's a thousand gigabits per second
That's a thousand of these lines of internet
Huh, you could transfer. I could transfer my entire computer in eight seconds
Or I'll leave this one to you
Which one would you guys rather have a flying car or one terabit per second internet?
Connection both are good
You could get the flying car and panned it or you could do whatever you want you could download the entire
internet on a one terabit for a second
Which one would you guys rather - so thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought down in the comments
Below as always. I will see you in the next video bye-bye